parliament will set out its position on
the digital green certificate which aims
to facilitate a return to eu
travel it would allow people to prove a
negative test or immunity from covid19
meps will set out their red lines
including not discriminating against
people who haven't been vaccinated
parliament will vote on the ratification
of the trade and cooperation agreement
cementing a new partnership with the uk
meps will reiterate their calls for the
uk to stand by its commitments in the
withdrawal agreement
especially concerning northern ireland
the pandemic has shown that research and
innovation have never been so important
parliament will vote on the 95 billion
euro horizon europe program
investing in research across the eu from
preparing for future health threats
to helping the transition towards
climate neutrality
meps will vote on new rules to prevent
the dissemination of terrorist content
online
the proposals include a europe-wide
legal definition of terrorist material
and oblige platforms to remove illegal
content within one hour
parliament will vote on rules to improve
the experience of train users
the new legislation provides for better
compensation and help in case of delays
more space on trains for bikes and
easier access for the disabled